Mara how are you I'm doing fine good how
come home I was calling because I'm a
full-time student I'm about a year left
in school part-time waitress so my
income is low and I happen to rack up
quite a bit of credit card debt over the
past five years just from horrible
spending habits and lately I have been
taking out extra student loans to pay
down on that credit card debt no to that
long times a lower interest rate no yeah
so altogether right now I've got about
fifty nine thousand dollars and that
forty seven and student about seventeen
hundred in a car loan and then about ten
thousand in credit card still so you
have a question yes my question is
obviously should I keep doing okay no
you're not used to doing those to pay
credit cards okay do you have any advice
on my income about sixteen to twenty
thousand dollars per year with my
waitressing so it's just kind of
unmanageable right now okay well your
first goal is of course to eat and keep
the lights on your second goal is finish
school when will you finish school I
will be finishing next summer so about a
year and about a year okay less than a
year good so if you can tread water till
then and I had no more new debt that's a
victory okay then the second thing would
be to pay the actual payments on the
credit cards just minimums and we'll
call that a victory and then the third
thing would be if you can actually start
to make some progress paying down on
those you don't you're not paying
anything on the student loans while
you're in school right using them as
leverage to pay off credit card yeah
it's a really really dumb idea you're
making a mess and so have you cut up
these credit cards cut them all up yeah
I don't use them I've switched
if you use them or not chop them up okay
stop using them you have to stop this
stuff radically and then the second
thing I'm going to tell you is you
probably need to work more or at a
different place well can't work more
because of my school schedule and out of
differences that probably make the best
tips in an area where I'm located okay
well a little more money another
thousand dollars a month change your
life Wow so that's what I'm looking at
is what can I do to create that just on
this short term you only got about nine
months to your income can change
hopefully with a new with a new job and
a new career at that point but hang on
until then and stop borrowing on student
loans to pay off credit cards